hey what's up everybody it's your boy
Travis H here we back again on 12 talks
going crazy today we got the Cookie
Monster drip hold
on Cookie Monster drip Cookie Monster
shoes oh oh there we go got the Cookie
Monster drip now we get onesy every
Monday fit tough like always first thing
we got is what I've been doing since
I've been hurt and main thing is me
fishing and yeah my recent YouTube video
fishing first time I
lost yeah lost bro
number she got like 10 freaking fish
giant that caught a big one
though I had to catch the big I a catch
the most but I
yeah LNA whooped my tail in fishing you
know she love fishing too she beat me I
caught the biggest one though that's all
that matters not the most the biggest so
yeah that's what it been that's what's
been going on oh yeah also the game this
past week we won that was great was
stressful for me to watch though not
going to lie I'm out there stressing but
yeah my boy shador shadora putting them
on notice ear with the TD those y he can
run he can
roll look at Z they
blocking good receiver man that's a good
receiver he have the
blocking that's good hey Shor I told
y'all he can run man don't sleep on that
boy running ability he can run he don't
like to do it often but when it's time
to run he going to get up out of there
and
run yeah put him on notice early in the
game second quarter 54 seconds
left going into half
time it was hard it was a hard
hardfought game but you still can't give
us the ball last and leave us too much
time on the clock cuz we are still going
to go down there and do our thing like
always let's play right here Javon he
just got to keep his feet he came in
showed up how he was supposed to
man he came in and showed up got him got
him a touchdown couple receptions got
got his confidence back so he go out
there and dominate like always man we
been knew he can go out there and
dominate he just had he had the
opportunity just haven't came through
when it was time and he came through at
the right time this time so it was a
great catch he went down he got him a
touchdown that game so was good then we
had
ma you know Ma don't miss man that's
what we call them Ma don't miss
we got faith Tom Mel man he always gonna
make
it could told him to go do his
dance went down and did his
thing
yeah Mo I mean guys you didn't believe
in Ma I believe in ma why you think I
brought him here ma don't miss you call
the time out and freeze him all you want
that don't mean nothing to ma ma he
that's who he is and that's what he
always says to me when I walk over to
him and get him a hook he said I don't
miss
and I love it so I told him to do your
thing do your thing get your
shine yeah Ma don't miss man put ma in
the game is a to back make for us and we
know that so we got full faith in him
Coach Prim got full faith in him we just
let him go there and do his
thing next we got shador showing off
student
section showing his wrist to the student
section get that out the
way
Conor was a bad game for us but hey he
know they was mad so he went out
there he knew it was mad so he went he
went over there uh show his wrist that's
how you make him more mad you know
haters always going to be mad anything
you do no matter if you do anything good
so he went over there showed him his
wrist flexed on him which I him doing
cuz it just show people that he don't
care he know he got to go out there and
dominate after he do things like this so
we know this upcoming game he got to go
out and
dominate yeah and he definitely doing
his he doing his thing nobody got more
passing guards than him hey it's nothing
else you can say more passing yards he
throwing touchdowns every
game I don't know what to tell you man
we got shador next telling
everybody
TR the play call um understand know what
time it is they left too much time on
the clock and we knew that nobody on the
sideline Panic Flinch nobody didn't
believe uh the coaches just knew like
what was going to happen and I
definitely knew what was going to happen
because you're going to do what it takes
to win but they simply left too much
time on the clock um and you know what
mode we went we went Brady
mode yeah BR mode every time you leave
too much time on the clock man we going
to find a way to come come back and win
it man and that's what we've been doing
since us at Jackson We Gonna Come Away
we're gonna find a way to make a play
and that's exactly way he did that's
exactly what we did even though we W
coach PR wasn't satisfied I wasn't
satisfied it was an ugly win that's not
what we into man we need to go out there
and garbage you I'm trying to figure
this out sick of it I'm happy about the
win but I'm not happy in the fashion
that we we wanted in we're better than
that I expect
to win I expect to win in a better
fashion than that apologize for my anger
today but I don't accept mediocrity
maybe you do maybe you can live with it
maybe you sleep with it maybe you lie
with it maybe you comfortable with it
but I'm
not yeah man it's pretty much saying
like it was a good win but at the end of
the day we didn't win how we wanted to
win we
played trash we came out with the dub
which is great but at the same time it's
not good
[Music]
man we have to got to get right man we
can't do that we play
trash but we still came with the win
can't take the win away we still play
trash but now it's time for overreaction
not overreaction let's get right into
[Music]
it first we got
ma might dance go
crazy might hit hit that stuffed taco
man
yes his dance do go crazy man can't get
mad at M M finally dance he don't dance
at all so this is kind of
funny there not over reaction
man I would might have hit that jump
next see you him are cold not over
reaction those H was tough I wish I was
able to play in them that face mask is
crazy that face mask is
crazy
play like hot garbage in them though I
wish he would have blowed them out in
the good looking helmets
but it's all
good just leave this man
alone
yeah yeah man not a overreaction bro
leave him alone I get they trying to get
the ball but come on man that's too much
right there there's just extra stuff
that doesn't even matter like just pick
up the ball for it go back bad for y'all
just cuz y'all did that all right there
we
go I don't know if he want no high but
that's a good
play I just don't understand what the
defender was doing he really thought he
was going to cut back just tackle him
get it over
with I said I wasn't in the moment I
don't
know that was a good play
over
reaction next this is the worst loss in
college football
history yeah this kind of is the worsal
bro I had to do his KN man it's not hard
just trying to get extra stuff doing
extra stuff and when you do extra stuff
stuff like this
happens shmer drills find open grass
find open man
touchdown hey not overreaction at all
this got to be one of the worst loss man
you lose when you know you could just
nail I need it was two nails and you was
good well one nil actually and I was
game but
yeah most people don't know how to play
video games though I don't get this
one hey you right though sometimes you
that's what it look like need to do for
coaches bro I don't know what they be
thinking bro one minute 30 seconds left
you got I got to do you up by three need
two first downs really
one need one first
down they got one time out nobody is
safe on the sidelines yeah buddy I seen
that
play yeah you better be paying attention
to that game anything can happen you can
get ran into rolled up on over hit with
the ball all types of stuff
cameraman
down Cameran down back in the end zone
bangers not over reaction better be
ready on that s line nobody safe anybody
can get
it good taco technique From the Rough I
think I've seen this
one that's over reaction though he Ain
even wrap up
reaction man rough a WRA up he ain't do
his good he a do job he a do his job he
a even tackle how they teach us to
tackle this is not how they drew this
one up let
see hold
on what the hell was that not a reaction
they definitely didn't drive up like
that he should have just kept the ball
and went down he spiked
it yeah they tripping with that one it's
definitely not overreaction they
definitely DED up like that well I guess
they drew it up like that but it ain't
go how it was supposed to be SK got a
decent stti for him pop it
up oh got
KN yeah stiff arm hey go out his way
stiff arm
hey it's not overaction he stiff on them
boys to the dirt
one
two
three
four
five they all lining up to get stiff on
bro you definitely got to get stiff on
boy stiff on them kids to the
dirt
all right y'all know
man the go for Jeopardy is 700 to win
all right we about to play some Jeopardy
I know I play football I'm always
screaming I love the fish so let's play
some
Jeopardy
boy G yeah gaming 100 I'm going gaming
100 first
bro where your the fortnite come out
2017 I know that because I didn't even
play it the first year and this is six
year it's six year anniversary that's
easy uh yeah do fishing
100 this word could be used to describe
fishing equipment as well as a position
in
football bro what what is
this I got to get this
y'all got to
think
equipment
equipment what you mean by equipment
though oh
tackle I'm thinking yall talking about
like bait or
something tackle is
easy all right fishing 200
man this fish is considered the most
popular game fish in America game fish
like eating wise
or like game fish like the fish
for oh fishing wise
bass that's
easy yeah got football
200 am I like that that's defensive
player to win the hman trophy Charles
Wilson am I right yeah I know that one
cuz I'm like that again 200
bro 200 is crazy gaming 200 bro
name the last three NBA 2K cover
athletes I don't know 2K 23 I know 2K 24
is
Kobe 2K 23 and 2K
22 one of them was uh what's his
freaking he played for the Suns is it
was it yeah Devin Booker
bro what's the last one bro
Kobe was it
LCA Luka D LCA
dun
yeah game over
bang bang I'm like
that just a goat man just a goat should
I do football 100 what is football 100
this for usfc head coach and current NFL
head coach has also coached the New York
Jets and New England
Patriots that's for you is
that I forgot his
name uh what's you USC head coach
name Riley something like
that oh you said former I thought it was
current I'm
tripping my bad my bad I still got 700
though that's so I
want like
that next up we got a blur let's get
right into
it
oh hey that's a blur Bean top head top
blur whatever you want to call it one
hand grab is crazy Ain couldn't even get
his other hand out that should really be
a pass
interference cuz
Godly can't even let my boy get his hand
out good catch though where time got up
for this TD C let
see oh that's blur on his
head he got
that that's that sound let me see hey
foot hey oh yeah that's touchdown blur
for show for
sure hey blur Big Boy blur is
crazy big man blur is
crazy I I let him do his dance Too coach
I ain't just head top somebody as a d
that's
crazy
[Music]
blur he just took it off his head now
that's a blur bro those good blurs this
time good blurs good blurs y'all
understanding that's a blur head top
comes a blur yes over the top good blur
man before we get out of here gotta talk
about Friday night game back at home
vers
Stanford hey we just got to come out
fast we haven't came out fast yet other
than TCU we got to come out fast ready
to go that's the main focus this week
come out fast put in the bed early you
gotta know our assignments play Fast
discipline gota play with a character
can't have that many penalties gotta
save our
timeouts we we just have a lot that we
got to do that we got to understand like
we can't keep messing up we got to come
out fast we F to go deep into the season
it's time to show show everybody what we
talking about when we come out fast it's
we unbeatable I feel like we gotta come
out
fast uh be focused the whole week it's a
Friday night game back in high school
kind of I think it's late night game
too but yeah we got to come out fast
ready to go get
ready but yeah that's what we got to
do so make stay tuned we going have a
good game this Friday night make you
stay tuned for the game make sure you
stay tuned for the next uh podcast
Monday it's your host Travis Hunter with
12 talks and we out
peace